the saw time line is really well thought
out despite the fact there are constant
flashbacks retcons and events being told
out of order you can still piece
together everything in a way that makes
sense except for the history of disco
Logan Madison if you want to see how
Nelson breaks the time line and my idea
of how it can be fixed then stick around
to the end of this video hello and
welcome to horror history and my name is
the professor not that Professor
professor sees these world and in
today's lesson I'm talking saw more
specifically the most recent of jigsaws
many disciples lieutenant Logan Nelson
Nelson made his debut in the 8th movie
jigsaw and there's still unanswered
questions about his character that may
be left open for future installments as
hinted at by the directors the spirit
brothers I will talk about those
possibilities but before we can get
there we've got to take it back to the
debut of the first disciple Logan Nelson
was born on August 18th 1973 he grew up
to become a medic and at 6:00 to 195
pounds he was also a pretty big force to
be reckoned with when Logan was 29 he
was doing his residency in metropolitan
city at the angel of Mercy Hospital the
same hospital that dr. Lawrence Gordon
was treating a patient named John Kramer
one day in 2003 he was responsible for
labeling a couple of x-rays and
accidentally switched the labels an
event that prevented John's doctor from
correctly diagnosing his brain tumor in
its early stages that small mistake
ended up being one of his biggest
mistakes because it was this that caused
Kramer who would one day become known as
the jigsaw killer to include Nelson in
his first ever game a challenge that
included five contestants fighting for
their lives to prove that they cherished
life he is put into a room in a secluded
barn with four other wrongdoers but the
sedation used on Logan doesn't wear off
at the same time as the others so by the
time he wakes up he's nearly already
been pulled into a wall of spinning saw
blades he ends up getting cut by the
blades leaving permanent scars on his
back but luckily John realized that he
didn't have a fair chance and didn't
want him dying over an honest mistake so
he ran out to save him and give him a
second chance after stitching up his
back he made Nelson his apprentice
teaching him jigsaws moral code and
engineering techniques together they
built what would become known as one of
jigsaws most iconic tracks the reverse
bear trap and John would impress the
mantra will speak to the death which had
a great impact on Nelson going forward
john's partnership with a nelson would
come to an end however later that year
when nelson shipped out to serve in the
military
where he was a lieutenant from May 2003
through July 2005 though it was
automatic in Fallujah Fallujah is short
for Al Felicia a city and Iraq were two
of the biggest battles of America's Iraq
war took place
Keith Hans also served in Fallujah and
mentions that even as a medic Logan took
out some Taliban guys before being
captured he was tortured possibly with
hydrofluoric acid which he recognizes
the effects of as a medical examiner
years later according to Nelson's file
he was imprisoned by Republican Guard
loyalists for five months and 11 days
during his imprisonment along with four
other members of his medical patrol he
was subjected to an array of
interrogation methods for the purpose of
discovering his units plans and for the
recapture of Fallujah this is almost
certainly where he developed his
stone-cold demeanor
we see it later when he's being
questioned by Keith Hans and of course
at the end where he goes full punishment
mode lieutenant Nelson was released in a
prisoner exchange brokered by Army
General Fitzpatrick in May 2005 at which
time he was transferred to vis and v
Virginia Capitol health care network in
Maryland where he received PTSD
treatment for 23 months in other words
he was still jumping at shadows after
getting free so they treated him in a
hospital for veterans from May 2005
until April 2007 during that time and
patient exhibited signs of extreme
anxiety and antisocial behavior for
approximately seven weeks much like me
when I'm editing a video during which
time dr. Perry prescribed a regime of
serotonin reuptake inhibitors or SSRIs
with limited success we don't know
exactly when Logan met his wife but it
seems like his daughter was conceived in
December of 2005 while he was still
under treatment
- Nelson was eventually released under
his own recognizance on August 9th 2006
but suffered a severe relapse following
the birth of his daughter Melissa
lieutenant Nelson lashed out at a
neighbor with a yard sign and was
arrested following an argument with his
wife's physician and much Logan
repeatedly struck the doctor in the head
and was later sued for injuries man I
wonder what that yard sign said go
figure
Nelson considered himself a broken man
after the war ten years ago I came out
of the war a broken man yes that's what
I just said but jigsaw helped him put
the pieces of his life back together
again like a jigsaw puzzle see what they
did there now this is where the timing
of events gets a little bit wonky
because I don't really think lieutenant
Nelson linked up with jigsaw again after
the war
long story short because jigsaw was
pretty busy with some other stuff at the
time and he was
by the time that Nelson had his big
three laps and yard sign incident I
think what Logan means what that line is
that it was jigsaws teachings that helps
him eventually overcome the PTSD there
are some other possibilities but I'll
talk about those a little bit later he
was readmitted to VISN v on september
12th 2006 and improved steadily
throughout the rest of the year
Nelson was re-released on December 12
2006 and has not been prescribed SSRIs
since May of 2007 he was released from
the care of dr. Angus Perry on February
10th 2007 and his breakdown in the
summer of 2006 is considered an
aberration and dr. Perry signed off on
his condition insisting that Nelson is
not a threat to himself he was awarded a
Purple Heart on October 5th 2007 so all
of this from 2003 to 2007 being in the
war overseas and dealing with his own
mental illness battle back home helps
explain why he as one of jigsaws
disciples wasn't a factor during the
seven Psalms which take place from 2004
through 2007 not including flashbacks so
this point an argument can be made for
the morality of Nelson's character but
what would happen after returning to the
metropolitan area caused him to take an
ever darker outlook on life
logan used his knowledge in the field of
health care to become a medical examiner
not long after the jigsaw saga had
concluded but despite jigsaw leaving a
lasting legacy on the city criminals
eventually started to run rampant again
and bodies continued to pile up during
his first year in County the body of an
8 year old girl showed up on Nelson's
examination table an event he felt could
have been prevented it happened one day
after detective Halloran who I'm just
now realizing I don't know the first
name of captured a predator named Alice
Dora Schultz and brought him in for
questioning but during the interrogation
he got too rough resulting in Schultz
getting off on a technicality where he
quickly took his anger out I'm an
innocent young girl
Logan held this against Halloran for a
long time which wasn't helped by the
fact that this was the first of many
transgressions on Halloran's parts as
innocent bodies continued to pile up on
Nelson's table well okay they didn't
literally pile up he looked at them one
at a time probably but as the body count
continued to grow so did Nelson's
disgust for detective Halloran and his
methods he also called Halloran an
impulsive toll in the media a couple
times which created a tension between
the two that everyone knew about it
wasn't just Halloran's excessive use of
force that bothered Nelson now he also
had a penchant for letting criminals off
the hook the most notable example was
Edgar Munson a meth addict thief and
assaulter who wiggled out of two arrests
because he was Halloran's informant I'd
sight the lack of discipline as a major
reason that Munson never cleaned up his
act and ended up committing the most
heinous crime of all putting ketchup on
a hot dog now I'm just kidding he
murdered Nelson's wife I think it was at
this point that Nelson probably started
plotting his revenge with jigsaws words
we speak for the dead is still echoing
in his head with his unique position as
the county medical examiner and with his
close proximity to Halloran and his
department Nelson began paying close
attention to the criminals that Halloran
led off of the hook his aim was to
recreate the game that jigsaw had placed
him in all of those years ago using
criminals from Halloran's botched cases
along with Halloran and himself
Nelson discovered his first candidate in
2011 a degenerate gambler named Malcolm
Neal was partially responsible for the
death of his wife when people he owed
money to broke into his home and slit
mrs. Neal stroked Halloran never managed
to put him away for the illegal gambling
charges and Neal fit the profile of one
of the guys from jigsaws original game
at the bar so Nelson took things into
his own hands to punish it over the next
five years he kept his eyes open and
found two other criminals that he deemed
similar to the other two contestants of
John's game at the bar in 2016 he
abducted them and put
them through their own game as expected
they made the same mistakes as their
predecessors did though it's not really
clear if Nelson made the game's winnable
like jigsaw did or if he was just
torturing them to avenge the dead the
game began when Nelson abducted his
wife's killer Edgar Munson and left him
in an abandoned warehouse with an audio
tape created by splicing together old
archival audio of John Kramer to make it
look like jigsaw was back from the dead
and conducting a new game surprisingly
it didn't end up sounding like a bad
sound board Franco the tape told months
and he had to get to a certain rooftop
with a trigger that would start the next
game he arrived there chased by police
and each of them aims to destroy the
trigger not knowing that Nelson was
watching from another rooftop with a
sniper which he used to shoot Munson
simultaneously after using his inside
access to obtain a capsule of John
Kramer's blood he injects it into
Malcolm Neal's fingernails before
putting the bloody body on display in
public for police to find and ultimately
bring back to him and to examine with
his very lovely assistant Eleanor bonfá
in fact he wisely allows her to be the
one to notice the jigsaw piece he had
cut out of the victim's head she doesn't
notice the flash drive lodged into his
face
so Nelson makes sure that the police
know about it by bringing it to light
himself on the outside of it the text
reads and then there were four the drive
contains an audio file so why don't we
just as jigsaw and his other apprentices
did during the saw saga Logan is leaving
this as a message directly for detective
Halloran that evening Nelson would
deposit the next body from his recreated
game at the pig farm this one was
supposed to resemble a woman named Carly
from the original game he tosses her
body from the rooftop of st. Peter's
Hospital the same hospital where Edgar
Munson is being treated for his gunshot
wound this time the body had a sign that
says and then there were three the
purpose of counting down like this is to
crank up the pressure on detective
Halloran and force him to solve the
mystery to find and put a stop to the
game while there are still living
contestants to rescue however it's all
of
because the only two living contestants
at this point are Nelson himself and
detective Halloran who is being lured
into this games location by the sly once
again Nelson has called in to examine a
corpse that he created this time
dropping more hints by pointing out that
the victim was killed by hydrofluoric
acid not a rooftop fall a nice little
homage to one of jigsaw straps and saw
six where the same acid is used in the
game where'd William Easton is executed
it's also probably a satisfying act for
nelson who was also tortured with hf
acid during his time being imprisoned in
the war before the last member of the
game has revealed something strange
comes up with Nelson's assistant Elinor
that completely changes Logan's plan
that night Logan has to stay late at
work and video chats his daughter and
the babysitter to say goodnight
highlighting what I think is a possible
weakness for him going forward he
clearly cares a lot about his daughter
there's only one jigsaw Prentiss have
past who as a kid I'll give you a clue
they used to worked at the same hospital
together Lawrence Gordon found out how
hard it is to have your child taken as a
hostage if part of jigsaws game way back
in the first movie but we've also seen
similar tactics used to manipulate
characters like Eric Matthews and Jeff
denlon after getting off the calls
detectives Halloran and hunch confront
Nelson and explain that his hot
assistant
I mean his assistant has been sending a
lot of web traffic to a website called
jigsaw rules and no I'm not sure if it's
called that because they're fans of
jigsaw you know like yeah yeah bro
jigsaw rules he's the best or if it's
more of a reference to the fact that
jigsaw holds these games where the rules
have to be followed it's also unclear if
all of that traffic was coming from
Elinor or if Logan was also responsible
for some of it Elinor obviously used it
for her weird hobby of recreating saw
traps but Logan could have used it at
some point as a resource for his version
of the barn game this is where Logan's
intellect comes into play what makes him
more dangerous than some of jigsaws
former disciples he's able to turn this
dangerous situation into his advantage
and here's how he does it first he
defends Elinor even though making her a
suspect could be advantageous for him
instead he uses reverse psychology by
protecting Elinor instead of himself he
causes the detectives to actually become
more suspicious of her it's not a
hundred percent clear if he knew he was
being followed that night as he found
Elinor at the Brewers Moon and got her
to take him to her studio a warehouse
filled with her own recreations of
jigsaws now famous
but upon seeing this collection Nelson
realizes how he can further use it to
confuse hunt who's tailing them by
muddying the clarity of the situation
Elinor shows him the human blender which
he recognizes from Kramer's barn game
but he plays dumb telling her that no
victims died in anything like that it's
amazing that he was able to keep a
straight face through all of this
perhaps highlighting in sociopathic
tendencies because Logan already knew
full well that the next victim of his
version of the barn game was killed in a
blender just like this one so he plotted
the plan to the next body in Eleanor's
studio he was especially busy that night
though he also had time to kidnap Edgar
Munson from the hospital under the nose
of the sleeping guard and relocate his
body into the tomb of John Kramer who is
set to be dug up in the morning in order
to prove to the public that he was still
dead this of course sent people into a
frenzy lending more credence to the idea
that the original jigsaw had returned
from beyond the grave
Logan never planned on Eleanor being a
jigsaw fangirl or Kramer's body being
dug up but he was able to stay calm and
turned both of these potential
subversions into advantages and that's
what makes him such a scary carrier of
the jigsaw legacy he's able to suppress
the rage that used to get him in trouble
after the war and become a collected
calculating psychopath which is my
favorite kind of villain the next steps
after that were pretty easy but would
not be without a couple of challenges
the most obvious was to plan to cut out
jigsaw pieces and Halloran's freezer
remember the goal isn't to pin the crime
on Eleanor she's just a distraction for
the cops right now the real one to take
the fall has to be Halloran
then Keith hunt shows up to arrest
Nelson thinking he and Bonneville are in
cahoots together and killing the new
victims again he's able to turn the
situation on its head by offering all he
knows essentially making it look like
Halloran is the one trying to frame him
he cites the evidence that lines up
perfectly with Halloran being guilty
because he set everything up that way
all of the victims are Halloran's old
cases and he gave the order to shoot the
remote that Munson was holding way back
you know when that happened
Logan was the one who fired it but
nobody knew he was even there in order
to fully clear his name
Nelson suggests that they go back to the
medical table and examine Munson when
hunt isn't looking he switches the
bullet with the one from Halloran's gun
this is honestly kind of the flimsiest
thing in the movie I mean the body has
already been moved by the killer at this
point so I don't see why said killer
couldn't just switch the bullet out I
guess hunt didn't think about that
though because it works hunt takes
Nelson home and starts to investigate
Halloran giving our boy Nelson
find Eleanor well she finds him with the
news that she's discovered the location
of the game
this is perfect for Logan I think at
this point he realizes that Halloran is
following him and all he has to do is
let Eleanor lead them to the barn
exactly where he wants how around to be
for the final round of the game the one
wild card here is miss Bonneville so
he's got to find a way to get rid of her
for a little while to give him time to
deal with Halloran
once again Nelson finds a way to turn
this problem into a positive by
convincing her that Halloran is the
killer and engaging in a fight with him
he tells Eleanor to run before dragging
Halloran and taking him to the slaughter
room now he has one more person
believing what he wants them to believe
someone he probably wasn't even counting
on being involved the final round of the
game is no game at all it's a trap but
unlike John Kramer's traps this one is
inescapable
he poses himself inside the room
opposite the detective fabricated audio
of John Kramer's voice tells them that
they can escape death if they admit to
the reason they deserve to die the whole
thing is a setup to get Halloran to
admit to being a dirty cop all Nelson
has to do is sell it so he gives Hal
around the chance to choose who makes
their confession first letting him
choose is secretly the ultimate power
move because if he chooses himself he'll
probably confess but if he presses
Logan's button then he can sell the
scenario even further because his collar
is equipped with fake lasers and fake
blood so that's exactly what he does he
fakes his death in order to scare
Halloran into making his confession a
confession of tampering with evidence
taking bribes putting away innocent
people letting the worst criminals walk
free and letting innocent people die
more than enough to convince most people
that Halloran is the one behind the 2016
killings with that evidence Logan no
longer needs his rival and after
explaining his plan like a typical
villain he activates the real laser
cutters and executes detective Halloran
yeah if anyone knows where I can get one
of those things I would love to have it
to cut my grapefruit so remember how I
said there was an issue with Nelson's
timeline yeah there's an issue with
Nelson's timeline let's see if we can
make some sense of it
to roust jigsaw characters are
constantly going around saying that
jigsaw can't be back because he's been
dead for ten years there's been dead for
ten years John Kramer's dead and has
been for ten years see I told you that's
why I've been saying that Nelson's game
takes place in 2016 10 years after
jigsaws death in 2006 but at the end of
the movie when Logan does his evil
villain speech he says that John's
original game which he did is a secret
test before all of the other games was
ten years ago ten years ago in this very
barn a game was played well the first
game was in 2004 so it can't be 10 years
since 2004 and ten years since 2006
simultaneously not if both games are on
earth anyways the other confusing thing
is that Nelson says jigsaw helped them
put together his life after the war you
may remember that he didn't start to
recover until September 2006 which is
actually after jigsaw died so all of
this doesn't quite add up as neatly as
the seven solids but there may be a
simple explanation well the simplest
explanation is that they up but there
may be a cannon explanation as well
there are two options really the first
is that the game at the barn didn't
really take place before the bathroom
game in October 2004 it is stated that
jigsaws barn game took place before all
of the other games but what if it only
took place before all of the other games
that the public actually knows about the
earliest known game would be the nerve
gas house and saw - which happens in
October of 2005 that gets us pretty
close to 10 years but it would actually
be 11 years in 2016 but it's easier to
clump the game and the rest of John's
life together as one event if you do it
like that
but there is one snag in that theory
which is that Eleanore studio has a
replica of the hacksaw from the bathroom
you know the one that Gordon used to
escape which means the public did find
out about the bathroom game at some
point so the barn game probably took
place before the bathroom game there's
also the fact that we see Logan and John
building the reverse bear trap together
and the reverse bear trap is invented
even earlier than the bathroom day we
see Amanda tested by it in May of 2004
that's why I made this video under the
idea that jigsaws barn game took place
shortly after Logan Nelson switched
John's x-rays in 2003 and Logan Nelson's
barn game took place 10 years after
jigsaws death in 2006 this makes the
information on Nelson's file fit nicely
into the series because it
perfectly explains by Nelson never
helped John during saw one through seven
because he was at war for part of it and
busy being treated for PTSD for the
other parts as for Nelson's line and
years ago in this very barn a game was
played I think it's possible that he was
just generalizing he was essentially
saying this was all about a decade ago
it's not like he's been counting year by
year but he knows it's been at least ten
years since John Kramer's barn game and
about ten years since his death the last
retort that Halloran tries is when he
points out the fact that John Kramer
gave victims a choice to try to win the
game and Nelson's response to that is
just savage role that you have a choice
scream or don't
so Nelson actually ends up committing
the murder himself unlike jigsaw but a
lot like some of his other failed
disciples like Amanda and Hoffman Logan
Nelson is both a warrior and a tactician
once grooms to be the next successor to
jigsaw things went horribly wrong when
his rehabilitation was interrupted by
service in the military the
post-traumatic stress that is often a
symptom of mental illness and Army
veterans ends up warping and distorting
his still rehabilitating mine into a
sociopath and a psychopath the likes of
which we've never seen before
combine that with his scary physicality
and extremely sharp and fast-acting
intelligence and we could have one of
the scariest villains in the Saw
franchise going forward at the end of
jigsaw the only confirmed survivors
among jigsaws successors are Logan
Nelson who's strayed from the path of
John's teaching and Lawrence Gordon who
has protected his legacy for the last 12
years
both are medical masterminds who have
also taken on the arts of mechanical
engineering and deductive reasoning one
has the advantage of brute force and
military background and the other has
ten times the experience being jigsaw
and to unknown apprentices helping him
out hopefully we get to see these two
masterminds battle it out jigsaw vs.
jigsaw in a future movie it would be an
epic battle that Forever Changes the
franchise going forward so that's it so
far for the history of Logan Nelson
click the video on the left to see more
analyses of your favorite horror
characters here on horror history and
let me know which saw character I should
cover next remember subscribe to see ZZZ
world for new Horrors every week bring
that DEATH BATTLE for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive
[Music]